hello everybody shut up nurse god damn
it it wasn't raining for two seconds
then suddenly I hit the record button
and it's outside the ring okay it's a
little too early to get in so let's just
get into it I've passed all the other
ones with Dee and everyone knows that D
stands for diploma although I'm not a
medical school in Nicaragua anymore but
I'm sure that this will go just fine
okay
so we're on the last surgery but not the
last thing to offer for this game
because I know there's an ambulance
level in a space level and I'm gonna get
to later but I'm gonna beat this for
what it is right now okay enough intense
camera action alright so what we're
gonna do mmm is we're gonna bash this
guy's brain out quite literally I'm not
even joking about bashing the brain out
we're just gonna be wrong did that hurt
oh poor baby suck it up it's just a
brain you don't even need it
alright hey brewski and get the last bit
of that brain out of there or the last
bit of that skull is what it's called
sorry it's been a while since I've went
to medical school I don't really
remember what these things are called
he's bleeding a bit but not too much so
let's just whoa hello well you popped
out of there quite easily let's just
expose that brain stem for a second and
then we can get the scalpel in there
excuse me Hamar you've been very useful
but I do not need you at the moment this
requires some delicate finger work here
mmm just get it whoa hey don't get too
excited they're not into the brain just
cut that brain step whoop so gently it's
like a little butterfly and just chuck
that over there alright so anyway we
didn't even need any of these other ones
we just needed our pure skill as a
surgeon in here so let me just grab that
and lift that out of the jar and then
just blob it doesn't matter what
orientation just hey yeah I did it
record time I'm the greatest surgeon in
Nicaragua I am the greatest look at me
go oh I'm so amazing I'm all excited now
because I did good all right
now that we did that let's see if we
can't get let's see if we can't let's
see we haven't unlocked any other one so
I got to get this disc in and oh my
goodness is gonna be hard I've tried I
tried to get this in before but let's
see okay what we're gonna do okay get
this oh shut up nurse I don't have time
for your shenanigans
oh my come on oh no you don't know I
need the one on top pan ah there we go
okay
y'all just settle down geez I need to
get this let me actually put this on a
flat surface so I can maneuver around it
because I knew Oh aah Oh that actually
worked
thank you no no no no no no no no no no
stubble it's a finger
oh you were correct before no ah that's
up what the hell it was correct and then
it goes flying off the table what the
hell is this gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme stop flipping there's a
finger there I don't want to want to go
to the finger there I wanted to go to
the finger I could do the finger
manually but right now I got it what is
what is this [ __ ] no you son of [ __ ]
come here aah
the surgery went well but this is even
harder your son of [ __ ] okay you know
what to excuse but you guys from seeing
my rage I'm gonna just cut it and I'll
come back once I get this in maybe or
maybe you guys want to see this maybe
you guys want to see my frustration stop
touch another finger get it why are you
dying oh just get gently gently push it
push it
angularly oh my god this is unbelievable
shut up nurse okay just turn it kind of
damnit it won't there's no way to rotate
this Oh what was that
oh okay wait Hans hold on what no that's
correct okay it's in the correct
orientation so let's just pop this out
and then pop this in I don't know how
but it somehow went to the correct
just grab it gently ha ha ha ha ha ha
this may not even be the right disk I
have no idea
ha ha what is this what is this okay
well that's just brain surgery that
doesn't help you at all
wasn't there one of these disks that
unlock the other mode hang on this
probably read one britannia 88 isn't
britannia is that like a medical book of
some sort I don't know I don't know
let's just get the red one in there coz
it's dungeons of doom mmm my favorite
come on there's no way to rotate them
it's frickin impossible there with no
almost almost almost got it just grab it
by the co my god this is oh why why what
now get off of the phone oh my god
you're in the wrong way
okay guys we're back sorry about that
I lost a little control but we got the
missions on the side here that we we
have we got the ambulance and the Spade
wait wait I'm on the space mission right
now says I'm in surgery no I'm a man I
saw the space mission it was there I had
it where'd it go oh whatever we got to
do ambulance mode cuz you know what
forget it I don't even care anymore I
didn't see that before but it was
obviously there okay so let's perform a
heart transplant somewhat in the goodly
direction of surgery unlike what
happened before get over there don't go
on my tool okay I'm not gonna be too
rayji I'm not gonna be too big because
being rayji is not good thing Reggie is
an unacceptable hi hi hey don't knock my
day I'm trying to smash some ribs here
but just cool your jets
hi God get the fun on the road if you
can't drive you don't even deserve to be
here
oh my god this is this is not correct
[Applause]
god damn it mother
god this is gonna be so much worse this
is gonna be so much worse I'm gonna lose
my mind before the day is out oh my god
you got to be joking you gotta be joking
me this is unreal and there goes my
watch and there's a fire extinguisher
why is there a fire extinguisher Jesus I
can't because the oh the watch is now
blocking me from turning my goddamn
wrist you gotta be [ __ ] with me this
is such [ __ ] this is such [ __ ]
stop it stop moving around God why would
someone want to play with this why would
someone want to do this yeah just know
[Music]
it's bad enough that I'm not even
holding this this oh you [ __ ] we're
all right [ __ ] it you know what you did
it for me good job
where's my bleeding syringe oh my god
the my heart the heart I'm supposed to
do it's all over the place
hang on ah you gotta be joking me gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme oh no i've
turned on the drill now the drill is
gonna destroy him when it goes sliding
all over the place to stop the bleeding
there we go put that over there it's um
clear these out of here oh my god this
is unbelievable whoa why would someone
want to do that and the back door is
wide open why why is the back door of
the ambulance wide open nobody makes any
sense
ah my wrist holy [ __ ] hell did I look
there's my heart my heart better stay
there my heart is now drilling into the
drill is now drilling the new heart at
Fantasma coal oh my god I'm these this
guy's gonna die just because I'm gonna
lose his heart the heart is gonna go
flying out the back and there's nothing
I can do about it all right just slice
that and then slice the arteries at the
heart and let's get this out of here we
do not have much time he is bleeding and
I okay I slice the heart okay get that
where's my where's my aunt I bleed oh
there's this aunt I bleed oh come here
please please please please cooperate
cooperate cooperate cooperate cooperate
[ __ ] not me just a [ __ ] ah normally
this would be fun but this is not the
time I'm gonna lose him you dying man
he's dying he's dying man let's go pull
in there wide no no no no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I can't see can't see what the [ __ ]
can't see oh yeah [ __ ] I can't
see goddamnit grab onto something grab
on to summon Pole I can't see what's
real I can't see what's real okay I got
something ah what what what what what
where from
absolutely is the heart nod all the way
out of there or is this stomach just
being an [ __ ] this stomach is being
an [ __ ] or is it the liver that's in
the way I can't [ __ ] tell what's my
real hand get out there the liver is out
ah [ __ ] hammer stop chipping away at
him you're losing my blood I only have
so much blood left get dick he's stomach
you're pretty much your cut what are you
doing in there still stomach get out of
there did I not cut at the base I don't
care I can't even see I don't even think
there I can't even tell where the other
syringe is I don't even think it's there
it is Hannah we just try to jab myself
here oh no oh man god damn it all a [ __ ]
balls what is that that the liver go
back in the liver just went back in the
liver just went back in why liver you're
supposed to be out of there what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] that's just a horse
this is the worst this is worse than it
was before you go chill out with Bob's
face over there and I can't
I know it's cut cuz I cut them before I
started tripping balls and I just
launched the other syringe off the table
for no reason and god damn it I'm so
this game is like this game is the worst
for my health because me personally my
blood pressure goes through the [ __ ]
roof I can't get it and there's nothing
to grab all right I'm gonna if there's
even a scalpel left I'm gonna try to
slice some I don't know what's still
stuck there but I'm just gonna I just
gotta try to slice something but he's
gonna bleed out and I can't get it with
this god damn it you [ __ ] scalpel
you're in the wrong way it the right way
am i higher than I was things are
tripping balls even worse
god dammit there's another scalpel just
magically appeared I don't care it's a
godsend I don't care it wasn't there
before but it's gone it's it's not okay
I think I cut that I get it this time
did I actually get it I'm
he's not losing any more blood I think I
might have gotten it hang on yeah yeah
yeah yeah I got it I got it oh my god
please just let me get it in there let
me get in there is it real real real
real it's gonna pop out of there he's
losing blood oh my god no it's it's
right it's right there oh my god is the
stomach in the [ __ ] way it is isn't
it what the [ __ ] is this get out of
there it's at the radio oh my god I'm
gonna kill myself oh my god my hand I
can't see anything hearts can stay in
their heart what why don't you just
I am sweating
I am literally a [ __ ] mess I am you
see this I'm sweating this is
unbelievable
I was about to kill myself this scheme I
can't play this game anymore it is too
bad I can't take it personally I'm going
to die if I keep playing this [ __ ]
game I'm going to lose my mind I am
seriously I'm a [ __ ] mess I'm gonna
have to go do tai chi or yoga or I'm
gonna have to meditate cuz I'm so
[ __ ] stressed there's a [ __ ]
bullet
okay you are talking to the camera I'm
talking to the window of the other camp
that can't see three to you guys I can't
play this game in the world this is done
I'm done
I can't do it gonna be uh I'm gonna I
can't do it
that's just not your possible anymore
cuz I'm gonna lose my mind and then you
guys are not gonna have any more petty
else to do there's no mo being the
intense huh I'm not gonna be able to
play this game anymore we're gonna [ __ ]
everything about it ah okay
don't anyway here I got a massive
headache right now like my headed
pounded man so thank you all so much for
watching click the interface of four
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]